welcome back to this fine show
they cracked down on the best player in
tennis but isn't fauci the real Menace
Novak Djokovic has withdrawn from a
major tournament after being denied
entry into the U.S because he's not
vaccinated against govid he'd requested
a vaccine waiver but was rejected by the
DHS
the tennis player who's from Serbia
which is a country is currently
currently ranked number one in the world
and number two in my dreams after Mike
Lindell
and as a world-class athlete who has
antibodies his chance of getting ill
from covet is the same as me taking
Taylor Swift back not happening
and as a young pro athlete with
antibodies his chances of sickness are
the same as kilmead's Amazon reviews
zero
that was totally unnecessary
the event includes matches in Miami so
Florida senators Rick Scott and Marco
Rubio wrote a letter to the president
reminding him that he himself said the
pandemic was over although it's not like
Biden to forget things like how to walk
upstairs meanwhile
House Republicans on a committee probe
in the pandemic say they've uncovered
new emails that show fauci worked to
discredit claims that covid leaked from
a Wuhan lab said in February 2020 fauci
prompted researchers to write a
scientific paper to disprove the lab
League Theory then weeks later at the
White House cited that same paper as
evidence that the theory was bogus while
acting like he didn't know its authors
there was a study uh recently that we
could make available to you where a
group of Highly qualified evolutionary
virologists looked at the sequences in
bats as they evolved and the mutations
that it took to get to the point where
it is now is
totally consistent with a jump of a
species from an animal to a human I I
don't have the authors right now but we
can make that available too nice try
even the bat said what a load of guano
you know what this is like you know what
fun fauci did it's like a restaurant
writing its own Yelp reviews to deny
that they poisoned the customers when
they did
but bad things happen when you let an
unaccountable unethical blowhard spent
decades in government you end up with
global pandemics that kill millions and
worse forcing us to do a story about
tennis
I finally found a sport worse than
soccer Brian it's not true there are two
great Sports they have an international
quotient to them that you're not
familiar with first off I didn't know
this was the interview I didn't know
this was the international sign for a
bat virus so he goes it's the bat to the
bat to the bad to the bad everybody
knows so this is like Yuka you
commissioning cat or Tyrus to write a
view of who is the best late night talk
show host and being surprised yes that
they name you and this to me is so it's
so aggravating also when it comes to
tennis there's nothing safer than
playing tennis against somebody
vaccinated run vaccinated there's nobody
around you there's no one around you
you're breathing fresh air to the
outside who rejected this man he's got
two more years at the top of his game
they're denying two tournaments sold out
crowds this is just a I'm embarrassed
that this is the government it denies
his Serbian a country Serbia is a
country a chance to to see their
National play here is that what you're
embarrassed by I'm just interested in
what you get embarrassed by well you how
come you don't listen to what I say I
listen
[Applause]
you said and the answer to who stopped
him from coming in was the Department of
Homeland Security so thank God for them
to keep us safe from Serbian
unvaccinated tennis players I you know I
would say that I was shocked at this
department that was created 20 years ago
to keep us safe from terrorism has now
evolved into doing something completely
different and useless rather than just
being gotten rid of but that's not
shocking at all no
said
should the DHS storm the NFL games to
prevent people from spinal cord injuries
or from being paralyzed don't give them
any ideas
each other right and we're like and we
got to put we got a Administration Jamie
that's saying no we must protect the
what are they protecting the ball boys
[Laughter]
I don't you know it's funny I was
actually I was a ball boy for a while
but it was for the I was what the
audience I
really was I really was but it was for
the wrestling team yeah
we had to make sure the uniforms were
tight enough this is crazy
disgusting
just embarrass it really is this guy's a
22 time Grand Slam Champion he should be
black when I was drinking I was the 22
time Grand Slam champion at Denny's
um
this is the first time by the way um
tennis always reminds me of my marriage
because love equals zero
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're really leaning into this aren't
you
is it part of this though this is when
have you ever heard before getting in
trouble for doing a sport for not doing
a drug yeah yeah
do you know what I mean like he's got a
it's like a backwards it's all I
remember when I worked at Arby's they
would they would um is there a punchline
to that because you could stop that I
know the setups are killing
um but when I worked at Arby's they
would drug test us test us and if there
was even a tiny bit of marijuana in your
system they would let you keep your job
and um
Insanity though let them play yeah if
that glassware or not you're a big
tennis fans I'm a big tennis fan how do
you feel about this if you're a
president would you issue an executive
order and say free the Serb
uh I would do what a chief executive
does is if an employee isn't doing their
job you fire them start with Anthony
fauci or the likes of it
if you run the Federal
for you you don't work for them and so I
get rid of these Civil Service
protections so we don't have to deal
with the likes of him ever again over
the course of this and the thing I
Djokovic you know it makes me mad is you
know what he played here in New York
City in 2021 wherever you are in the
debate coveted was worse than you had
vaccines for nine months and yet now
after the pandemic is over years after
it's irrelevant now it's a virtue signal
so it actually has nothing has about as
much to do with covid as the Spanish
Inquisition had to do with Christ which
is to say nothing at all it is a toxic
religion and you know what good for
Novak Djokovic he's at least standing
his ground you know what he's losing
Grand Slams but he is the man doing it
yeah
what were you thinking about when he was
talking I was thinking about I can't
believe I'm doing a segment on tennis
ah this is good man you know you're
nodding rapidly tennis is fun you know
when you got nothing to do
Greg I'm with you I actually got I got
tennis elbow from changing the channel
from tennis
the best part about tennis is smelling
new balls
oh
yeah we didn't smell too many of them
yeah they smell great they do remember
you'd open up the thing fresh yeah fresh
yeah it's like a drug right it's like a
drug what's the last time you do uh new
work week
[Applause]
you know what hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else